because of our height difference i
obviously if we're on the same like
point we touched we were attached my
feet would swing from underneath me and
then she would catch me
tom holland and zendaya seem like a
perfect match even if they can't
literally see eye to eye i am sweating
in the lead up to spider-man no way home
swinging into theaters the couple is
treating everyone to their chemistry on
and off screen i'm excited we're gonna
have a good press tour i think good call
zendaya because you're in tom's
appearance on the graham norton show had
it all including this hilarious behind
the scenes anecdote i heard you talking
some reason there how your height
difference makes those stunts more
complicated thank you graeme
as the couple explained web slinging
across new york city was easier said
than done now that is a good story it's
like the story well you see there's
there's a particular stun there i don't
know if it's in this but there's a you
know he spider-man swings us on top of a
bridge and he places me there and that's
the bridge because of our height
difference i obviously if we're on the
same like point
we were attached i would land before him
because my feet obviously hit the ground
before he does
yep and you got to stick the landing if
you want to be a superhero
and she would land and then i would sort
of land like this and my feet would
swing from underneath me and then she
would catch me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're actually very very lovely about
you were like oh my gosh thank you
it's so nice to be caught for a chat
plus during the chat tom also recalled
the time when he was taken down a peg
while auditioning for peter parker
everybody's a spider-man you know
spider-man belongs to everyone
apparently someone said he would nab the
role even if the prediction was a little
backhanded when i was going for my last
audition
i was driving there i was very nervous
and i had this driver lovely guy but a
little bit too honest sort of sitting
there really awkward he's looking at me
he's looking at me he goes you know what
kid i think you're gonna get it
you might really why because
the kid that i just drove there
he is so good-looking
[Laughter]
and tom said the interaction later got a
full circle moment after he was cast you
know i've got the part i was lucky
enough i saw him a few months later when
i was shooting the film and he goes i
told you i thought what did you tell me
that i was going to get the part or that
was ugly
but hey at least zendaya didn't seem to
think so tom i just feel very lucky the
couple was snapped packing on the pda
all year and zendaya gave e.t her
reaction to the massive fan response
all right i got to ask you what is it
like to know that you broke the internet
those pictures of you and tom and people
were so excited because they're like
spider-man mj it's real like it was like
the world was rooting for this moment
well i'm i'm excited for the film to
come out i can't wait for everybody to
see um spider-man when it does come out
and you know we we all work so hard
we're all so you know we're all so close
from that i just thought it was cool
because people were actually rooting
they were you know look the internet can
be a cynical place and it was overall
joy it seemed when those pictures came
out well thank you
[Music]